[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE TEODORESCU:
Hello, and welcome
to this module on choices
of fairness criteria.
My name is Mike Teodorescu.
I'm an assistant professor
of information systems
at Boston College, as was a
visiting scholar at MIT D-Lab.
What we'll cover
in this module will
be the concept of
confusion matrix,
as well as three popular
examples of fairness criteria--
demographic parity,
equalized odds,
and equalized opportunity.
Some countries have
laws that protect
specific groups of people
from discrimination
based on certain attributes.
As we review in
the previous video,
these are called
protected attributes.
Some examples are on this slide.
Regardless of the
legal landscape,
machine learning
has the potential
to produce unfair outcomes
for certain groups of people.
As an algorithm designer,
one should make clear choices
about fairness criteria.
Some criteria will be reviewed
in the next few slides.
[? In the ?] previous video, we
also discussed case of fairness
through unawareness,
which refers
to leaving out the protected
attributes out of your model.
And we also explained why
this is not a good choice.
Specifically, you may end up
with other attributes that
correlate with
protected attributes,
and you may end up
discriminating inadvertently
nonetheless.
In order to go into
additional fairness criteria,
we need to discuss some
additional concepts.
Consider you have a
binary classifier.
For example, you're
looking at decision of hire
or not hired or to lend
credit and not to lend credit.
If we want to look at the
predictions for a model that
would do such a
binary classification,
we would look at the
predicted values.
We could bucket them in four
categories-- true positives,
which would be
correctly classified
as positive, true negative,
as negative, false positives,
which would be values that
were incorrectly classified
as positive by the algorithm,
false negatives, which would be
values incorrectly classified
as negative.
And, if we were to add
the the true positives
to the true negatives and
divide that by all four,
we would end up with the value
of the accuracy of the model.
In this example where
accuracy is this fraction,
an accuracy of 0.5 is the same
as a random classification.
Now we should look
at accuracy carefully
and see that it doesn't tell us
anything about the prediction
of negatives.
It could mislead us if two
classes were imbalanced,
for example, if 90% of
the sample is positives,
and 10% is negatives.
For that, we have other
additional criteria
we could go into deeper, such
as MCC score and AUC score.
The true positives, true
negatives, false positives,
and false negatives are,
oftentimes, represented in a 2
by 2 matrix form called
a confusion matrix.
This is simply an easier
presentation for us
to see the behavior
of the classifier.
The first additional
fairness criteria
is called demographic parity.
It's a criterion for what's
called group-level fairness.
This criterion specify
that the outcome, which
here is denoted by a
y hat, is independent
of the protected attribute A.
For example, the probability
of being hired is
independent of the gender.
There are multiple problems
with demographic parity.
One would be the
definition that we just
discussed would
not hold if we had
individuals who would be members
of multiple protected groups.
By enforcing group-level
fairness for one attribute,
we would still violate
the group fairness
for other attributes or
combinations of attributes,
such as subgroups
of the population.
Furthermore, while enforcing
group-level fairness,
for example, the same hiring
grade for females and males,
that could still be
unfair to individuals.
It could force the algorithm
to drop otherwise qualified
individuals just to
achieve independence
of outcome of the attribute.
Fairness at the group
level could, potentially,
be unfair at the
individual level.
For example, if we have a
high rate of false positives,
we could end up-- and a low
rate of false negatives,
it could still end up
being unfair to individuals
in that we could hire
people who are without merit
at the disadvantage
of other individuals
who could be qualified
and should be hired,
but, due to the group-level
fairness criterion,
we have to hire some
who are not qualified
from one of the groups.
The sweet spot would
be low false negatives
and low false positives, which
would be fair, potentially,
to both the individual
and the group level.
We could also end up in
the top right corner, which
would be the worst-case
scenario, low accuracy,
unfair to individuals, but
potentially fair for the group
where we have high
false negatives
and high false positives.
A stricter criterion
is equalized odds,
which means matching both
of true positive rate
and the false positive
rate for different values
of the protected attribute.
This is much harder to achieve
than demographic parity,
but it is one of the higher
levels of algorithmic fairness.
In this case, rather
than predicting
the same average
risk across subgroups
of protected social attributes,
like in demographic parity,
equalized odds is stricter
in that it forces equality
only among individuals who
reach similar outcomes.
In the hiring example
that we've discussed
in the previous
video, this implies
that the probability of a
qualified applicant to be hired
and the probability of
an unqualified applicant
to be incorrectly hired should
be the same across genders.
A milder version
of equalized odds
is equalized opportunity
where we're only
concerned with treating fairly
those who are determined
to be worthy of acceptance,
i.e. dependent variable
is equal to 1, or
they're worthy of being
hired, worthy of being
admitted, and so on.
Equalized opportunity is not
concerned with rejecting people
fairly across protected groups.
So to speak, the false positive
rates and the true positive
rates do not both need to be
equal across the protected
categories.
We only need the
true positive rate
to be equal across
protected categories.
In a way, equalized
opportunity is
less interventionist
than equalized odds,
and it may be more
achievable, depending
on your individual situation
and implementation challenges.
In the example of
hiring, we only
are concerned with individuals
who are worthy of being hired,
i.e. the actual
qualified applicants.
And, out of the
rejected applicants,
we may be sometimes
rejecting unfairly.
Here's some review questions
for the last two videos.
What is demographic parity?
What is fairness
through unawareness?
Is fairness at the group
level always the best?
What is a confusion matrix?
What is the equality
of odds criterion?
And when might you
want to use it?
This course is sponsored by the
USAID grant through MIT D-Lab.
And this is joint work with my
faculty colleagues Lily Morse
and Gerald Kane from Boston
college and research assistant
Yazeed Awwad from MIT D-Lab.
If you would like to
learn more about this,
please consult the
following references.
Thank you so much for
watching this video.
We hope you find it
useful and you'll continue
watching the rest of the class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]